tf à 20h avec roger gicquel ronald
reagan parle il commence actuellement à
los angeles sa première conférence de
presse moins de 48 heures après son
élection le groupe joue en difficulté il
accuse cette année un déficit de 1
milliard et demi de francs première
médicale française une greffe du poumon
elle a été réalisée à lyon sur une
accidentés de la route
baisse des températures aux des légumes
le froid sur presque toute la france edf
importe du courant bonsoir reagan galope
à toute allure vers la maison blanche
il ne perd pas une minute il est déjà
tout à fait dans sa peau de président il
a loué des bureaux à 500 mètres de la
maison blanche pour que lui et son
équipe soit plus près des dossiers car
il faut que l'équipe républicaine qui
remplacera l'équipe démocrate le 20
janvier soit parfaitement au courant des
affaires de l'état
carter est d'accord pour que la
continuité soit assurée de cette façon
rien d'aussi urgent d'ailleurs celui des
otages nous le verrons dans un instant
oui regan met les bouchées doubles hier
il a convoqué sa bande
enfin son futur gouvernement dans son
ranch de los angeles et au moment où je
vous parle il fait là aussi dans ce
ranch sa première conférence de presse
de président élu
christian bousquet et michel bader son
talent écoute en direct et ils nous en
compte une rendre compte de cette
conférence de presse à la fin de ce
journal c'est une conférence de presse
qu on va éplucher d'ailleurs dans le
monde entier puisque on connaissait son
programme le programme de reagan à
travers sa campagne électorale il faut
savoir maintenant s'il a évolué depuis
son élection
je remarque que tout de même que léonid
brejnev à féliciter ronald reagan dans
un télégramme en exprimant l'espoir que
son activité de président servira les
rapports entre les états unis et l'union
soviétique dans l'intérêt des deux
peuples et dans l'intérêt de la paix et
les commentaires de la presse soviétique
font d'ailleurs preuve de modération
allen sinon de bienveillance à l'égard
de reagan en accusant carter d'avoir lui
voue l'usap et le principe de la détente
cela dit je reviens au début le dossier
urgent à régler entre carter et reagan
c'est de savoir s'ils sont d'accord sur
la manière d'obtenir la libération des
otages de téhéran de washington
dominique bromberger
ne vous y trompez pas quand jimmy carter
a quitté la maison blanche qui hier pour
se rendre à camp david
c'était avec esprit de retour la
constitution américaine prévoit en effet
très clairement que le président sortant
restent en fonction et assume ses
responsabilités pleinement puisque à la
fin de son mandat autrement dit jusqu'au
20 janvier proches
carter lui même a déclaré qu'il
continuerait à assumer toutes ses
responsabilités dans la sphère des
otages et au département d'état on
disait que si l'équipe reggane seraient
tenus informés des développements
il n'était pas question de mener les
négociations avec les iraniens avec
carter reagan ensemble aux commandes de
l'opération
a priori cette attitude semble arranger
tout le monde
regan ne souhaite certainement pas
entrer à la maison blanche avec 52
américains toujours aux mains des
iraniens tandis que carter verrait
certainement avec satisfaction sa
présidence se terminer avec leur retour
au pays
en fait vu de téhéran ce n'est pas aussi
simple
les conditions posées dans le domaine
financier notamment impliquent pour le
retour des avoirs iraniens ou pour la
récupération d'une partie de la fortune
du chat une coopération qui va durer
plusieurs mois
or certains leaders religieux
gouvernementaux s'inquiète du fait de
savoir si reagan tiendra les promesses
que carter pourrait faire alors que
devant le capitole les préparatifs pour
la cérémonie d'inauguration ont déjà
commencé une conclusion s'impose il
faudra bien une coopération des deux
équipes d'ici là pour régler la question
si rien dans la constitution ne
l'exigent et de pratique relativement
régulière
le problème est que dans le passé les
élus et les sortants n'ont pas toujours
fait preuve de bonne volonté dans leur
rapport à cette occasion peut-être cette
fois-ci le fait que l'intérêt de carter
et de reggane soit de voir les otages
rentrer le plus rapidement possible
aidera-t-il à surmonter les blessures de
la campagne électorale ce n'est pas vous
le savez seulement reagan qui sort
victorieux des élections c'est tout son
parti républicain et il obtient
notamment ce parti la majorité au sénat
et il se renforce à la chambre des
représentants alors avec encore 2 min
gamberger
l'ampleur de ces changements dans
l'histoire du congrès
ricains dominique bromberger donc avant
cette défaite de carter il aurait fallu
remonter à 1932 pour assister au
spectacle d'un président élu et non
nommé comme c'était le cas de gerald
ford se faisant battre au cours d'une
tentative de réélection
1932 la date est symbolique car avec
l'élection de franklin roosevelt
elles marquent l'ouverture d'une période
de près de 50 ans où les libéraux vont
dominer de new deal en nouvelles
frontières et de nouvelles frontières en
grandes sociétés la vie politique
américaine et où même les présidents
républicains eisenhower et nixon devront
dans une certaine mesure tenir compte de
leurs idées 1980 au contraire marque
l'acte de décès de ces libéraux partout
ils ont été battus balayé george
mcgovern en tête est remplacé au sénat
par des ultraconservateurs l'état du
massachussets le symbole du libéralisme
en amérique l'état des kennedy qui en
1972 avait été le seul à voter mcgovern
contre nixon a donné cette fois ses voix
à régal et la nuit de l'élection
ted kennedy s'est tu il est vrai que
depuis quelques temps ces libéraux
américains donnait l'impression d'être à
bout de souffle et à court d'idées ces
dernières années les idées en amérique
sont plutôt de droite et si reggane
réussi c'est peut-être une longue
période de conservatisme qui s'ouvre
pour l'amérique
dominique bromberger tf1 washington de
quoi demain sera fait l'amérique c'est
une question de quel poids va peser
cette nouvelle amérique sur le reste du
monde et sur l'europe en particulier
c'est la question pour nous de loin la
plus importante dans quelle mesure
allons nous payer la facture du
redressement américain
certaines paroles devrait déjà nous
inquiéter le bras droit de reagan
voudrait réduire de 10% les importations
aux etats-unis 10% chaque année pendant
trois ans mais les américains ne se
priveront pas d'exporter en même temps
ils ont déjà contre attaquer dans un
domaine précis celui d'automobiles une
marque américaine ne se vende t'elle pas
d'avoir vendu cent mille exemplaires
d'un nouveau modèle chez nous en
quelques semaines
or justement voici qu'en france la crise
automobile se révèle aux granges
en tout cas dans le groupe peugeot qui
annonce une perte d'un milliard et demi
cette année en 1980 les pertes se
situent surtout chez citroën et chez
talbot elles sont énormes et ne sont pas
évidemment sans conséquences sociales le
groupe peugeot fait les frais de
l'absorption de talbot et de citroën
dans le groupe
avec ce milliard et demi de déficit pour
1980 les pronostics les plus pessimistes
sont dépassés même si d'autres branches
d'activité de la société sont en net
bénéfice le grand responsable de ce
mauvais résultat est le secteur
automobile de la société récemment
intégré au groupe peugeot et sa talbot a
subi pour les six premiers mois de
l'année une perte sèche de 418 millions
de francs citroën a perdu également 317
millions pour la même période
seule peugeot automobile était en
bénéfices il ya quelques jours encore on
envisageait pour tout le groupe un
résultat positif
un résultat nul étant l'hypothèse la
plus défavorable mais avec les résultats
des six derniers mois de l'année
le milliard et demi de déficit sera plus
près de la réalité
pour la première fois depuis le début de
son existence peugeot est ça sera donc
en rouge cette année sans cependant
atteindre les niveaux de ses concurrents
américains qui annoncent des pertes
record
si en 1976 la conjoncture étaient
favorables à l'intégration et au
redressement de citroën l'année 80 n'a
pas favoriser l'absorption de talbot il
faut bien sûr s'attendre à des
répercussions sur le personnel de ces
sociétés en pleine restructuration
la direction de chez talbot souhaite 15
100 départs à la retraite anticipée mais
ceux ci restent encore suspendu à
l'accord du gouvernement
chez peugeot automobile et chez citroën
de telles mesures sont également
envisagées en fait près de 4000
personnes seraient déjà concerné par les
difficultés actuelles les récentes
déclarations du premier ministre selon
lesquels on pouvait difficilement
garantir dans l'avenir proche le
maintien du pouvoir d'achat ont fait
réagir tous les syndics
aujourd'hui encore andré bergeron de
force ouvrière a déclaré que les
organisations syndicales ne pourrait
plus signer d'accords contractuels
si le pouvoir d'achat devrait régresser
et puis il ya surtout aujourd'hui la
réaction du rpr le gouvernement
acceptera t-il enfin 12
le dialogue avec le mouvement politique
le plus important de la majorité et le
secrétaire général du rpr ben bernard
pons lançait ainsi annuler une ultime
fois un appel solennel au gouvernement
pour discuter de ses propositions
économiques et sociales avec ce
commentaire
monsieur bart ne veut pas reconnaître
son échec il accuse le malade c'est
inadmissible écoutez successivement
bernard pons et andré bergeron les
déclarations de monsieur raymond barre
devant le conseil économique et social
il ya 48 heures
nous paraissent constituer je les dis il
y à l'instant un événement politique
important puisque au lieu de répondre
aux appels que nous avons lancée il a
répondu parce que nous qualifions d'une
véritable provocation
aujourd'hui nous lançons une ultime fois
un appel solennel au gouvernement
le gouvernement acceptera t-il enfin
d'ouvrir le dialogue avec le mouvement
politique le plus important de la
majorité ou continuera-t-il à se
cantonner dans une autosatisfaction que
chaque jour les faits démentent
je ne conteste pas les difficultés de
notre époque
je sais que la tâche des gouvernements
n'est pas facile mais enfin il faut que
le premier ministe h que si on ne
maintenait pas le pouvoir d'achat les
organisations force ouvrière ne signerai
plus d'accord et cela peut avoir des
conséquences redoutables le froid encore
aujourd'hui sur toute la france seul le
littoral méditerranéen est épargné avec
10 degrés mais avec beaucoup de neige
dans l'est dans l'arrière-pays varois
uni soit demain des chutes de neige sont
annoncées sur le bassin aquitain le
matin puis sur le massif central et les
alpes il pleuvra beaucoup sur les
régions méditerranéennes et ailleurs le
temps sera nuageux et brumeux et la
neige n'est nulle part à exclure alors
cette vague de froid et de neige qui
perturbent la circulation partout qui
fait aussi monter les cours des légumes
abusivement ya beaucoup d'accidents de
chauffage tout un quartier de montereau
en seine-et-marne 4000 logements a été
privée de chauffage hier la chaudière
avait éclaté mais d'une façon générale
le directeur de l'énergie au ministère
de l'industrie affirme que la france est
en mesure de faire face à un hiver froid
avec une condition cependant que les
consommateurs soient disciplinés
alors la rubrique du froid et du mauvais
temps avec marie geneviève lemoine
nage sur toute la moitié ouest de la
france sur les massifs montagneux et
dans la vallée du rhône ce matin à
clermont-ferrand il y avait trente
centimètres de neige
on n'avait pas vu cela depuis 1923
circulation a été interrompue dans
plusieurs régions notamment sur
l'autoroute la catalane menant à
l'espagne ce soir la neige a fondu et
les chaussées sont glissantes il y aura
donc des risques de verglas
pour tous ceux qui prennent la route en
cette veille de week-end les opérations
de sablage sont en cours dans plusieurs
plusieurs régions
quant aux conséquences économiques l'edf
a déjà pris les premières mesures
elle importe 20% de l'électricité des
pays voisins en cas de nécessité
supplémentaires elle pourrait demander
aux entreprises dotées de leur propre
propre production d'électricité de se
découpler du réseau national
en effet depuis lundi on consomme autant
d'électricité con jours les plus froids
de janvier dernier
quant à l'approvisionnement du fioul
pour le chauffage
la france est en mesure de faire face à
un hiver froid
dernière conséquence le prix des légumes
a doublé rien que le chou-fleur breton
est passé de 250 à 6 francs ce soir
l'union fédérale des consommateurs
invite les français à boycotter les
légumes trop cher en tout cas pour
l'instant
on prévoit un radoucissement venant du
sud-ouest pour lundi prochain ou mardi
on l'espère bien ce radoucissement au
sénat suite de la discussion sur le
projet de loi du gouvernement sécurité
et liberté en présence du garde des
sceaux alain peyrefitte et les caméras
de tf1 ont largement suivi le débat
aujourd'hui diffusée en direct pendant
trois heures cet après midi avec une
première nous avons pu suivre les
travaux de la commission du sénat
travaux qui se déroulent habituellement
à huis clos
jacky dié nous résume ce débat
les objectifs de ce projet de loi qui a
été discuté cet après midi au céda sont
simples mais sa mise au point
extrêmement compliqué les objectifs
devant la montée de la criminalité
l'augmentation des agressions contre les
personnes âgées le pillage des demeures
les actes de vandalisme les objectifs
sont de restaurer la certitude de la
peine pour les délinquants et
d'accélérer les jugements le débat de
cet après midi a commencé par une
réunion de la commission des lois du
sénat suivie d'une séance plénière et
sénateurs ont montré qu'ils pouvaient
eux aussi se passionner pour un projet
qui touche profondément à l'évolution de
notre société vous faites une oeuvre de
destruction a dit monsieur lederman
communiste à monsieur peyrefitte le
gouvernement bafoue la constitution et
vous visez particulièrement le droit de
grève
monsieur cipollini socialiste vous êtes
en passe de devenir le ministre de
l'injustice monsieur mercier radical de
gauche
le texte marque une rupture avec
l'évolution de notre droit pénal depuis
un siècle
mais monsieur caldaguès rpr montre lui
l'importance d'une justice plus rapide
et il cite il rappelle un chiffre
effrayant
depuis 1975 il y a eu trois exécutions
capitales
mais dans le même temps 161 suicides de
prisonniers en détention préventive
et cela on n'en parle jamais le problème
de fond c'est qu'il ne faudrait pas que
notre justice devienne une justice à la
chaîne une justice de robots qui ne
tiendrait plus compte de l'individu mais
uniquement de l'infraction à toutes ces
objections
monsieur peyrefitte a commencé de
répondre cet après midi assez à l'aise
car il sait qu'il a une grande partie de
l'opinion derrière lui il aura
l'occasion d'y répondre plus longuement
ici au sénat puisque les débats se
poursuivront la semaine prochaine
la greffe d'un poumon a été réalisée
dimanche à lyon par une équipe de
chirurgiens français dirigé par les
docteurs du rau et pilliard la
bénéficiaire en est une jeune femme
grièvement blessée au cours d'un
accident de moto et il s'agit de
la première greffe de cet organe en
france de toutes les greffes seul du
poumon est la plus difficile depuis la
première effectuée aux états unis par le
docteur james hardie en 63 une
quarantaine de tentatives ont eu lieu
dans le monde mais al'inverse de la
transplantation rénale dont on connaît
les magnifiques succès la greffe du
poumon ne compte que très peu de
réussite
la survie la plus longue d'un greffé
pulmonaire n'a pas dépassé 10 mois
l'organisme rejetant la greffe assez
vite dans ce cas du poumon et pourtant
les chirurgiens lyonnais l'ont tentée et
si l'on osé c'est qu'il croit en sa
réussite pourquoi pire bourget il s'agit
en fait d'un cas extrêmement rare dont
on ne connaît que quelques exemples dans
le monde où la greffe pulmonaire
constitue le seul moyen de sauver
l'accidenté mais ce schéma va nous aider
à comprendre pourquoi la jeune femme
avait on le sait a subi un accident de
la route et son poumon droit présentait
des zones de destruction sur toute sa
longueur ce qui faisait que le poumon ne
pouvais plus remplir sa fonction
par contre le poumon gauche également
atteint lui aussi était atteint d'une
façon moins graves
alors qu'ont décidé les chirurgiens
puisque le poumon droit était hors de
circuit et que le poumon gauche était de
son côté 1 capable à lui tout seul avec
ce qui lui reste est de remplir son
office
ils ont enlevé le poumon droit
inutile et greffé à sa place
un poumon droits prélevés chez un
donneur qui est parfaitement capable à
lui tout seul de remplir les besoins de
satisfaire les besoins de l'organisme en
oxygène
il s'agit d'une greffe transitoire
c'est à dire que on espère que pendant
tout le temps où le poumon greffer sera
capable de faire respirer l'organisme
les lésions du poumon gauche cicatrisons
et que au bout d'un certain temps le
poumon gauche ayant retrouvé sa capacité
pourra à lui tout seul
remplir l'office des deux poumons à ce
moment là ça peut être une question de
somen une question de mois bien entendu
on enlèvera le poumon greffés et le
poumon gauche guéri espérons le
permettra à l'organisme d'avoir une
fonction respiratoire normal on le voit
il s'agit d'une greffe de transition qui
sera enlevée dès qu'elle aura rempli son
office
j'ai pris moi même ce soir des
renseignements à l'hôpital edouard
herriot à lyon
la malade se trouve dans un état aussi
satisfaisant qu'il est possible
on vient d'apprendre la mort du pilote
automobile français jean françois piot
qui s'est tué cet après-midi dans la 4e
étape du tour du maroc
son coéquipier mouren est grièvement
blessé piot a été transports le mou
rennes plus exactement a été transporté
à l'hôpital de fès nous revoyons sur ces
images jean françois piot a interviewé
récemment pour le magazine auto moto
monsieur étant rolland député rpr de
l'allier vient d'annoncer son intention
d'être candidat à la présidence de la
république il ne renoncera à son projet
at-il dit que si monsieur jacques chirac
est lui même candidat
si jacques chirac est candidat il va de
soi que moi même je ne serai pas
candidat alors pourquoi êtes vous
candidat regardez ce qui s'est passé aux
états unis au départ monsieur régal
n'avait absolument aucune chance
il a développé lors de sa campagne tu
râles les mêmes problèmes qui sont faits
de contacter le plan politique
économique affaires étrangères puissant
ce que nous n'en comptons dans notre
pays
aidez-la j'estime qu'il est
indispensable qu'une loi fasse connaître
à l'opinion publique française
les difficultés dans lesquelles notre
pays se trouve difficulté d'ailleurs
déjà ressenti et que un député comme un
appentis des solutions à ce problème
arlette laguiller a réaffirmé pour sa
part ce matin sa candidature à
l'élection présidentielle en annonçant
qu'elle avait recueilli 500 promesses de
signatures d'élus en vue du dépôt
officiel de sa candidature pour arlette
laguiller vous allez l'entendre la seule
solution à la crise
est la révolution sociale face à tous
ceux qui nous endorment en essayant de
nous persuader que tout va pour le mieux
dans le moins pire des mondes possibles
face à tous ceux qui nous berce
d'illusions en nous proposant de
rafistoler le système sol les
révolutionnaires disent clairement que
la seule issue raisonnable c'est de
mettre fin à ce système pour le
remplacer par un autre plus humain plus
juste plus respectueux des hommes et des
femmes comme de la planète qui les
portent des comités de soutien à la
candidature de michel debré à la
présidence de la république ont été
constitués dans 30 départements la liste
en a été rendu public aujourd'hui
cinq membres de la commission exécutive
de la cgt et militants du parti
socialiste s'inquiète dans une
déclaration commune je cite de ce que
pourrait être la position de la cgt
pendant la campagne des élections
présidentielles on voit dès aujourd'hui
ont-ils précisé au programme de tels
candidats vont les préférences de la
majorité de la direction de la cgt
l'union pour la démocratie française
vient de présenter un livre blanc est un
ensemble de propositions intéressant les
cales et ceci à la veille de l'ouverture
de la convention nationale de la cgc qui
doit à réunir environ 3000 cadre demain
à vincennes
cette convention va se prononcer sur la
présentation d'un candidat de la
confédération aux élections
présidentielles passation de pouvoir cet
après midi au secrétariat d'état aux ptt
norbert ségard a présenté son successeur
pierre rives à ses collaborateurs qui
ont travaillé à ses côtés pendant quatre
ans et demi
je vous rappelle que norbert ségard a
été nommé hier soir ministre délégué
auprès du premier ministre chargé
d'étudier les conditions d'adaptation de
la société et des administrations
françaises aux nouvelles techniques
pierre rib pour sa part qui était député
rpr des yvelines sera remplacé à
l'assemblée nationale par son suppléant
monsieur christian cloux mail sur tf1 ce
soir à 21h30 le magazine économique
l'enjeu de françois de closets emmanuel
de la taille et alain bel air au
sommaire les géants du rhin les grandes
compagnies qui contrôlent le commerce
mondial des céréales une dalle et
française
les révolutions du commerce quand les
géants de la distribution affrontent
ceux de l'industrie
enfin le drame de la côte d'ivoire une
réussite économique victimes de la
spéculation sur les matières premières
le magazine l'enjeu suivra un épisode de
la série les chevaux du soleil réalisé
par françois villiers d'après l'oeuvre
de jules roy
une série qui retrace l'histoire de
l'algérie c'est aussi l'algérie qui a
inspiré l'oeuvre de louis gardel
il vient d'obtenir aujourd'hui le grand
prix du roman de l'académie française
pour son livre fort saganne fort saganne
est publié aux éditions du seuil
excellente performance hier soir de
l'équipe de football de sochaux en coupe
de l'uefa
sochaux est allé battre l'équipe
portugaise de boavista porto par 1 but à
0 c'est le numéro 8 de sochaux durkalic
qui a inscrit ce but à la 75e minute sur
une remise de la tête de patrick revelli
but que nous allons voir dans un instant
le voilà
il a failli rater mais il a bien été
marqués et sochaux s'est ainsi qualifié
pour les huitièmes de finale de la coupe
uefa à tout comme saint-etienne
d'ailleurs il y avait à dire c'est
aujourd'hui à vincennes la combinaison
gagnante et le 9 le 10 et le 12 les
rapports dans l'ordre pour 5 francs 13
1657 francs 50 et dans un ordre
différent toujours pour 5 francs 2731
francs s'implante voilà alors gens
revenir maintenant à la conférence de
presse du président élu des etats unis
ronald reagan qui a commencé à lancer à
los angeles qui est maintenant plus de
24 minutes 25 minutes juste au début de
ce journal christian bousquet et michel
bader ont écouté cette conférence de
presse pour vous georges reagan élu
georges reagan fatigués certes mais sûr
de lui a eu deux temps forts
au cours de sa conférence de presse laon
sujet de l'otan l'autre au sujet des
otages
merci d'être venu at il dit bonjour je
suis très heureux d'être ici et je
voudrais remercier tous ceux qui ont
travaillé pour nous et j'espère ne pas
vous décevoir
nous allons commencer à traduire dans
les fêtes les promesses de la campagne
riham site alors les amis qui vont
l'accompagner pendant la période de
transition je suis reconnaissant à
carter de m'aider at il dit dans cette
période de transition
je suis d'accord pour partir sur une
base bipartisane en matière de politique
étrangère il y aura avec moi ford
question quel est votre ordre du jour
je tiendrai mes promesses les jeux
travaillerait avec le congrès
si vous besoin de vous pour gagner
j'espère avoir avec lui des rapports
d'equipe mais aussi d'amitié à la
question de la défense de ceux qui sont
persécutés
à propos de la pologne reagan répond la
politique agressive de l'union
soviétique sera discuté d'une façon
globale et non pas géographique avec
vous un plan pour libérer les otages
c'est un problème américain répond
reagan et le président carter est
toujours président nous l'aiderons mais
nous ne nous immisçons pas dans ce
problème
j'espère que les iraniens comprendront
qu'ils n'ont pas intérêt à attendre trop
longtemps
robin est une annexe à une question qui
lui est posée sur la future situation de
kissinger donald reagan répond nous ne
donnerons pas de nom pendant cette
période de transition
l'impression de représenter l'unité
nationale ou plutôt des groupes minutes
minoritaires le président et le vice
président à washington représente
l'amérique toute l'amérique l'amérique
en entier a répondu régal et comme
c'était un journaliste si l'américain
qui lui posait la question il a répondu
nous sommes voisins et nous ferons des
efforts pour rapprocher les peuples des
amériques dans leur détermination de
rester libre en ce qui me concerne je
ferai tout pour cela
en ce qui concerne le temps reagan
répond nous croyons en l'importance de
l'otan si nous voulons que nos alliés
est à nouveau confiance en notre parole
en la parole des états unis alors il dit
aussi qu'il faut que je rassure les élus
européens
des états unis j'ai la volonté de les
consulter sur toutes les décisions
importantes concernant l'alliance
atlantique
c'est la moindre des choses pas de
grande nouvelle dans cette conférence de
presse a priori parce que nous n'avons
pas encore tous les détails mais en tout
cas une volonté de reagan de dire qu'il
va s'entendre avec l'administration
actuelle et puis que il a l'intention
d'être ferme avec l'union soviétique
ça on le savait déjà voilà bonne soirée
à toutes et à tous au nom de toute
l'équipe de tf1 actualité merci de votre
attention et le dernier journal avec
joseph poli bien sûr en fin de programme